Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin heute hier hier diensthabende und für Sie zuständig arzt.
Bevor wir uns über ihre Becherven unterhalten, würde ich gerne über ihre Persönlien daaten,
einige frage ich, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Riccarda Joppe.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname langsam bustabieren?
Ja, Joppe schreibt sich J-O-P-P-E.
Riccarda dirite bustabe C oder...?
Ein C, ja, ein C.
Ich verstehe, und wie alt sind Sie?
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 m. Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, 1,69 m. Wie wiegen Sie momentan?
54 kg.
Am 12. Oktober 1978.
Hör Joppe, richtig?
Ja, ich spreche richtig aus, ja.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich werde Sie nicht verblenden, Joppe.
Also, ich bin in den letzten Wochen, bin ich sehr schnell erschöpft und auch sehr stark nervös und sehr schnell gereizt.
Das fällt auch meiner Familie auf, meiner Umgebung.
Sie wundern sich alle, dass ich mich so schnell aufrege.
Seit einigen Wochen ist das schon, seit mindestens 3 Wochen.
Sie sind erschöpft und nervös, haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich schwitze ziemlich stark, das erkenne ich sonst nicht.
Meine Hände sind oft unruhig, wenn ich die Tasse halten will, dann habe ich den Eindruck, dass ich die Tasse nicht ruhig halten kann.
Meine Kaffee-Tasse oder Tee-Tasse, ja.
Das finde ich sehr eigenartig, das so etwas kenne ich nicht.
Haben Sie Zittern?
Zittern auch, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie Halsschmerzen oder Husten oder Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind diese Beschwerden erst mal aufgetreten?
Ja, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Also mein Puls, mein Herzschlag ist höher, schneller als sonst.
Ich habe letztens gemessen, morgens beim Aufwachen, da hatte ich 100, ein Puls von 100, das kenne ich nicht.
Normalerweise ist mein Puls bei 60.
Wie haben Sie gemessen?
Ich habe hier am Hals gemessen und die Uhr gezählt.
Haben Sie diese Hörerpuls fühlen oder?
Kann ich fühlen, ich habe manchmal den Eindruck auch, dass das Herz schneller schlägt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Sturrbank?
Als Kind hatte ich oft Blasen und Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Zuletzt vor drei Jahren hatte ich eine Nierenbeckenentzündung.
Ich war gerade wieder bei einer Kontrolle beim Urologen.
Vor ungefähr acht Wochen oder zehn Wochen hatte ich noch mal eine Untersuchung mit Computertomografie.
Wie war das Ergebnis?
Das Ergebnis war wohl ganz gut.
Man sieht, dass die Nieren verändert sind durch diese häufigen Entzündungen.
Aber sonst war das Ergebnis wohl ganz gut.
Sturrkank habe ich bemerkt, dass ich in den letzten Wochen häufiger Durchfall habe.
Normalerweise habe ich regelmäßig einmal am Tag Sturrkank.
Jetzt habe ich häufiger Durchfälle.
Wie viele Mal gehen Sie Sturrkank?
Manchmal zwischen drei und fünf Mal am Tag.
Seit einer Woche oder?
Seit zwei, drei Wochen.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Kopchschmerzen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie sind auch müde?
Ja, schneller erschöpft jetzt.
Aber eben sehr nervös.
Ich verstehe, haben Sie Schlappprobleme?
Ich kann in den letzten Wochen nicht gut schlafen.
Ich kann nicht gut einschlafen, aber ich kann auch nicht gut durchschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Beides.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit aufwählige Gewicht verloren?
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich habe in den letzten sechs Wochen, schätze ich,
oder so Wochen habe ich bestimmt fünf Kilo verloren.
In ungefähr einem Monat?
Ja, in sechs Wochen.
Haben Sie Appetitprobleme?
Nein, ich habe viel Hunger.
Ich habe sehr oft Hunger.
Das kenne ich auch nicht.
Normalerweise habe ich nicht so einen Hunger.
Aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich muss etwas essen.
Müssen Sie sich viel Wasser trinken?
Nein.
Es ist jetzt zurzeit ziemlich warm, da trinke ich mehr Wasser.
Aber das glaube ich nicht, dass ich mehr trinken muss.
Nein, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Überkeit oder Erbrüchen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie sich winderlich?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie trockene Haut haben?
Ist mir so nicht direkt aufgefallen? Nein.
Haurausfall?
Nein.
Nicht so.
Nicht viel mehr als sonst auch.
Schwitzen Sie viel?
Ja, ich schwitze viel.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Ja, nachts auch.
Es waren auch die letzten Nächte, die sehr warm waren.
Da habe ich vielleicht auch mehr geschwitzt.
Aber es ist schon mehr Nachtschweiß als sonst.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie irgendeine allergie?
Ja, ich habe allergie auf Hausstaub und Polen.
Deswegen habe ich auch Asthma.
Seit wann haben Sie Asthma?
Das habe ich bestimmt schon 25 Jahre.
Sie haben Hausstauballergie.
Wie aussetzt die Allergie?
Asthma.
Luft in Atemnot.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unvertrecklichkeiten?
Zum Beispiel gegen eine Ernährungs-Mil?
Nein, ich vertrage sonst alles.
Haben Sie Medikamentallergie?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie Asthma haben.
25 Jahre.
Haben Sie Medikamente dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme einmal ein Mittel.
Wie Hani heißt das?
Wie Hani.
Soll ich Buch stabilieren?
Ja, wir können es nicht mehr.
Wir können es nicht mehr.
Das ist eine Art of Kapsel.
Ich tu ein Apparat und drücke drauf.
Dann kommt ein Nebel.
Den muss ich einatmen.
Das mache ich ein bis zweimal am Tag.
Je nachdem wie es mir geht.
Dann nehme ich bei Bedarf auch noch bero-dual.
Wie vielmal nehmen Sie bero-dual?
Bero-dual auch ein bisschen bei Bedarf.
Manchmal bis dreimal am Tag.
Aber ein bis zweimal.
Normalerweise.
Haben Sie andere Vorerkrankungen?
Einmal diese Blasenentzündungen,
die ich schon als Kind hatte.
Häufig.
Und auch Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Das war die letzte, wir ja vor drei Jahren.
Ich hatte vor einigen Wochen auch diese Kontrolle
mit Computertomographie.
Sonst habe ich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Sind Sie irgendwelche operiert?
Operationen habe ich gehabt.
Als Kind war ich glaube,
zehn Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich an den Manteln operiert.
Und vor ungefähr 10 Jahren
da wurde ich an den Nasennebenhöhlen operiert.
Weil ich hatte häufig Entzündung der Nasennebenhöhle.
Jetzt?
Vor zehn Jahren operiert hier an den Nasennebenhöhlen.
Das war das.
Weil die oft in den Süddeck waren.
Jetzt haben Sie Probleme mit Nasennebenhöhlen?
Nicht mehr.
Nach der Operation ist das viel besser geworden.
Ich hatte vorher oft Entzündungen der Nasennebenhöhle.
Dann hat man mir empfohlen,
vor zehn Jahren ich soll das operieren lassen.
Okay.
Und, hör ich auf, ich habe einige Frage.
Ich habe noch einige allgemeine Frage.
Über Ihre Familie und Familie.
Sind Ihre Eltern Leben?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch.
Mein Vater ist 32 Jahre alt.
Der hat schon seit Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Und meine Mutter ist 81 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch Asthma.
Ihre Mutter lebt noch.
Ja, 81 Jahre.
Wie hat Ihr Vater?
82.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Schwester.
Die Schwester ist 48 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch Asthma.
Und sie hat eine Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wir haben ein Kind.
Die Tochter ist 20 Jahre alt.
Sie haben eine Tochter.
Was ist Ihr von Beruf?
Ich arbeite bei einem Steuerberater.
Als Sekretärin.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit momentan?
Nein.
Ja, und rauchen Sie?
Nein, mich rauchen nicht.
Auch wegen dem Asthma rauche ich nicht.
Ich verstehe ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke mal ein Glas Wein.
Ich trinke 3 Mal pro Woche ein Glas Wein.
Für eine vorständige Krankengeschichte
muss ich auch Drogenfragen.
Nein.
Ich habe noch nie genommen und nehme mich.
Sie haben eine Vorstellung.
Ich gehe regelmäßig zu meiner Hausärztin.
Sie überprüft das mit den Impfungen.
Sie sagt, ich bin gut versorgt mit Impfungen.
Ja.
Ich habe Ihnen alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Das macht mir jetzt schon Sorgen.
Ja, Herr Joppe, ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Erstmal soll ich einige Untersuchungen
und Testen durchführen.
durchführen, danach kann ich ganz genau Ihnen sagen.
Okay, gut, das können wir so machen. Danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt seit einige Minuten so ein bisschen, dass die
Patientensprache, die Patientenbegriffe in medizinische Fachbegriffe zu umzuwandeln.
Und wenn Kollegen Fragen haben oder etwas wir etwas vergessen haben, dann bitte melden,
dann sollten Sie die Fragen bitte einmal stellen. Ich habe zwei Fragen. Ja.
Fühlen Sie Warm-In-Toleranz in der letzter Zeit?
Ja, warme In-Toleranz. Manchmal ist es mir sehr warm, dass ich in einem Klischöhrsitz
schon mal anziehen. Das ist mir aufgefallen, aber sonst nicht.
Und wurde Kontrastmittel beim Computer-Tomografie untersuchen benutzt?
Bei der Computer-Tomografie, ja, da wurde mir ein Mittel in die Wehne gegeben,
eine kleine Flasche, ein kleiner Tropf. Ich glaube, das war Kontrastmittel.
Okay, danke schön. Ich hatte auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie vielleicht Schwellung im Heißbereich bemerkt?
Schwellung, oder? Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Okay. Und können Sie gut schlucken?
Vielleicht eine Schluckbeschwerde haben Sie? Nein, schlucken kann ich ganz gut.
Das geht ganz gut. Okay, vielen Dank.
Hat jemand noch mal?
Das ist ein Training.
Hallo, schönen Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich bin heute bei Ihnen dänsthaben. Das ist dann Arzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen. Haben Sie für mich Zeit? Ja, habe ich.
Ja, es handelt um Riccardo Joppe.
Er ist 46 Jahre alt.
Riccardo ist eine Frau. Frau Joppe.
Sie ist 46 Jahre alt.
1,69 Meter wiegt 54 Kilogramm.
Das Geburtsstatus ist 12. Oktober.
1978.
Frau Joppe stellte bei uns in letzter 3-4 Woche
die Ärzte, die Trämer, die Müdigkeit, die Asthenie
und die Nervositöte und die Wärmeintroleranzen vor.
Sie gab an, dass sie Schweiß ausbrücke
und Hyperhoydrosis nocturna hat.
Sie berichtet die Patientin über vermehrte Hyperhoydrosis.
Die Patientin war seit 2-3 Wochen bestehende Diare.
Sie hat 3-5 Mal täglich.
Wie sieht der Stuhlgang aus?
Ist der Stuhlgang normal gefärbt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Der Stuhlgang ist normal gefärbt.
Kein Blut ist nicht dunkel gefärbt.
Sie hat keine Wormitis und Mosea.
Sie hat seit 2-3 Wochen Schlafprobleme.
Einschlafprobleme und Durchschlafprobleme.
Sie hat auch Trämer seit 3-4 Wochen.
Diese Beschwerden sind bei der Patientin erst mal aufgetreten.
Die Patientin hat 5 kg in der 6 Wochen abgenommen.
Sie fühle sich immer hunger.
Sie fühlt sich immer hunger.
Sie ist bei der Patientin seit 10 Jahren Mandeloperation.
Sie ist bei der Patientin seit 3 Monaten aufgetreten.
Sie arbeitet als Sekretärin bei einem Steuerberater.
Sie hat kein Stress beim Sozialleben.
Sie hat die Patientin seit 80 Jahren alt.
Sie hat die Mutter der Patientin.
Sie hat eine Schwester seit 48 Jahren alt.